Donald Trump was probably the biggest
person ever to be removed from social
media do you understand why that was
done Can you steal man the case for it
and against it and if there's something
broken about that how do we fix it still
man the case four is kind of obvious in
the sense of
um you are seeing a would-be dictator
who is trying to run a coup against
democracy who has his
um supporters go and storming the seat
of government who could use his app to
whip up his followers across the country
to reject
um you know the will of the people and
uh so you're an executive and you know
you'll take actions that while perhaps
controversial are still within the law
and you will make sure that you do your
part to defend democracy by making sure
that at least this guy's megaphone is
taken away and that his supporters
cannot organize more rights right that's
basically the case you know for the D
platform okay
um would you agree with that that's okay
so it's like really steel Manning it you
asked the steel man so I'm giving the
four case yeah well I think is I guess I
would like to separate
The would-be Dictator
oh I guess if you're storming the
capital you are a dictator I I see I see
um so those are two are interlinked
right you have to have somehow a
personal Judgment of the person bad
enough to be worth this
you know significant step yeah it's not
just their actions their words in a
particular situation but broadly this
person did everything that led up to
this moment and so got it right yeah so
that's that's a four case right now the
against case there's actually several
against cases right there's obviously
the Trump supporters you know against
case there is the
um sort of the libertarian slash
um left libertarian you know against
Case and there is the uh rest of world
against Case okay there's actually three
because it's not just two factions
there's multiple right so what is the
Trump supporter against case there's an
article called The Secret bipartisan
campaign that saved the 2020 election
right which came out um a few weeks
after uh the inauguration like February
4th 2021 and essentially uh the Trump
supporter would read this as basically
saying uh in the name of Defending
democracy the corrupted democracy
um you know whether it was actually vote
counts or just changes of all the rules
for mail-in ballots and stuff there were
regular meetings between the Chamber of
Commerce and you know AFL or and the
unions in particular they admit that the
BLM Riots of you know the mid-2020s were
actually on a string and they could say
stand down right so that's actually
that's a quote from this article where
it's like the word went out Stand Down
protect the results announced that it
would not be activating the entire
National mobilization Network today
remains ready to activate if necessary
code hoser credits activists for their
restraint so basically the activists
reoriented the protected results protest
towards a weekend of Celebration
so point being that
the fact that the Trump support would
say the fact that they could tell them
to stand down meant that the previous
you know unrest was in part you know
coordinated and said say okay so that
makes it illegitimate in a different way
right plus you know well there's one
Riot on Jan 6 versus the attacks on the
White House and stuff you know the
storming the White House in mid 2020 and
uh didn't actually storm the White House
but they're setting fires outside and
it's quite quite a lot of stuff right
so the second against Case is the let's
say libertarian left libertarian who'd
say
um do we really want uh giant
corporations regardless of what you
think about Trump and you don't have to
be a trump supporter do you really want
giant corporations to be determining who
can say what on the internet and if they
can de-platform a sitting president and
the quote most powerful man in the world
he's not the most powerful man in the
world in fact
um the quote people are electing a
figurehead and actually it's the heads
of network that are more powerful than
the heads of state
right that the fact that the CEOs of
Facebook and Twitter and Google and
apple and Amazon all made those
decisions at the same time to not just
de-platform Trump from Twitter which
literally billions of people around the
world saw but also censor or stop on
Facebook and to have Google and apple
pull parlor out of the App Store and
Amazon shut down the back end that would
be corporate collusion By Any Other Name
it's actually very similar to the
so-called business plot against FDR FDR
was
a complicated figure who can in some
ways best be thought of as the least bad
communist dictator or socialist dictator
of the 20th century why because he
nationalized the economy repealed the
10th Amendment right tried to pack the
courts he you know sicked the government
on all of his enemies from Huey Long to
Andrew Mellon obviously he interned the
Japanese which shows that wasn't really
totally a good guy right we don't
usually think about the same guy who did
this did that earlier in his life
um most people don't know this when he
led a whole Navy thing to entrap gay
Sailors and did you know about this one
no yeah Google FDR entrapment of gay
Sailors basically he got young men to
try to find folks within the Navy who
were gay and then
um basically entrap them so that they
could be prosecuted and what have you
right FDR did a lot of stuff but
fundamentally nationalized the economy
in and set up the alphabet soup is what
they called at the time and that's like
all these agencies or whatever and in
some sense he's you know like continues
like it there's there'd been a rising
trend of centralization Woodward Wilson
obviously centralized Lincoln
centralized right even actually you know
1799 was a degree of centralization over
the more you know like loose thing that
was 1776 1789 so he was on that trend
line but he's definitely a huge kind of
dog leg up so the thing is that because
of all the lawsuits that were flying
many you know Forks like uh Amy schles
you know has written a book uh the
Forgotten man and essentially her thesis
and thesis of many others at that time
like John T Flynn who's this journalist
who you know was pro-fdr and then was
against was that FDR made the Great
Depression great
okay then it wouldn't have been such a
bad thing without him mucking up the
entire economy and giving it a sickness
it would have recovered quickly without
that right this is a counterfactual
which people just argue about it really
angrily back and forth and you can't
actually run the experiment unless you
could Fork the economy right just like
were the bailout's good or bad I think
they're bad but how can I prove it I
need to actually be able to Fork the
economy crypto actually allows you in
theory to do that like where folks could
actually shift balances this is a whole
separate thing where you actually start
to make macroeconomics into more of an
experimental science rather than simply
arguing from Authority You could argue
from experiment
um some of the virtual economy stuff
that Edward castroneva has done is
relevant to this we can talk about that
point is though with FDR there's a thing
because he had Bridge such a war on
Private Industry at that time and
Justified it with this narrative bold
persistent experimentation there was
something called the quote business plot
where all these captains of industry
that he had been beating up and again
Teddy Roosevelt had also been doing this
with you know the trust Buster
um the journals at the time I'd Tarbell
had gone in you know basically ran all
these articles and Rockefeller knocked
him down Woodrow Wilson in The Skin
control but FDR the the CEOs were
thinking oh bad this is so terrible
there's a so-called business plot to try
to take over the government and uh stop
FDR from you know pushing the country
and what they thought was a bad
Direction Smedley Butler was a general
that they recruited to try to help them
with this but he turned on them and he
went and kind of broke the whole thing
open and told to Congress and so on and
so this guy's you know uh the the whole
plot was broken up all right now one way
of thinking about today or the you know
the whole aftermath of Jan six is it's a
business plot but in reverse because the
generals and the CEOs both were against
Trump and actually
the business plot happened and now all
the CEOs just you know they pulled all
this all the push all the buttons that
they needed to and now the network was
Prime over the state okay now why why is
that an interesting way of looking at it
because
one thing I have in the book is you can
kind of think in 1950 as like issues
Peak centralization you go forward and
backward in time things decentralize you
know for example and and you start
getting Mirror Image events that happen
with the opposite outcome for example
1890 the frontier closes 1991 the
internet Frontier opens internet becomes
open for Commerce okay you go backwards
in time you have the Spanish Flu
forwards in time covet 19. right
um backwards in time you have the uh
captains of industry the robber barons
Ford's in time you have the tech
billionaires and there's so many
examples of this like another one is
um backwards in time the New York Times
is allying with Soviet Russia to choke
out Ukraine now today they have
reinvented themselves as cheerleaders
for Ukraine against you know nationalist
Russia right and of course I think you
could absolutely support Ukraine on
other measures but it's pretty
hypocritical for the guys who profited
from the hall to more you know the ox
ellisburg family literally profited from
you know denying the hold more to now
make themselves cheerleaders for
Ukrainian sex with this insane thing
which we can talk about a tiny tangent
on the yeah you put it brilliantly and a
reminder for anyone who listens to me
talk about Ukraine it is possible to
have empathy for a nation and not be
part of the machine that generates a
mainstream narrative yes that's right
like basically you know I I was actually
one of the first three Estonian e e
residents okay and I completely
understand why Estonia and the baltics
and all these countries including
Ukraine that just recently within living
memory got their independence from the
Soviet Empire would not want to be
forcibly reintegrated
into a place that they just escaped from
you know and so that is something which
is sort of outside the American left
right you know tired kind of thing where
when you understand from that point of
view right then there's like a fourth
point of view which is like India's
point of view or like much of the
developing world or what I call you know
parts of it are you know ascending parts
or descending whatever but much of the
rest of the world outside of that border
region says look uh we're sympathetic to
the ukrainians but we can't allow our
people to starve so we're gonna maintain
trade and guess what actually you know
we've got a lot of wars in our neck of
the woods and human rights crises that
Europe just didn't even care about so it
can't be that Europe's problems are the
world's problems but the world's
problems are not Europe's problems right
so that's like a fourth point of view
then a fifth point of view is China
which is like guess what we're going to
be the Iran of the Iraq War you know
where like who won the Iraq War Iran
arguably extended their influence into
Iraq right so China's like guess what
we're going to turn Russia into our gas
station and build a pipeline they're
building there's a power Siberia is like
the name of the Eastern Russia your
pipeline just like nordstream is you
know Nordstrom one and North stream too
I think they're building a new pipeline
you know through Mongolia so Xi Jinping
and Putin and the Mongolian head of
state were all photographed kind of
thumbs upping this pipeline we'll see if
it goes through but it's ironic that you
know Russia wanted
to make Ukraine their you know Colony
but the outcome of this war may be that
Russia becomes China's Colony you know
so that's at least like five different
perspectives right there's like the U.S
establishment perspective there's the
you know Tucker Maga perspective there's
the baltics and Ukrainian perspective
there's like the Indian and like poor
countries perspective and there's a
chain Spectrum then of course there's
the Russians right so
um just respect to that by the way
that's another example of History
happening in Reverse this is the sign of
Soviet partnership except this time
China is a senior partner and Russia is
a junior partner and this time they're
both nationalists rather than communist
and there's so many flips like this and
you know there's I'm going to list a few
more actually because there's so so so
many of them do you have an explanation
of why that happens yes let me list a
few of them this is in the network State
book it's in the chapter called
fragmentation Frontier fourth turning
Futures our past right so I give this
example of like a fluid unmixing all
right just watch this for a second right
this is from Smart every day on mixing
color machine Ultra lamina reversible
flow smart every day 217. and so you can
mix something and then like this thing
that you don't think of as reversible
you can unmix it which is insane right
that it works okay the physics of that
situation it just works right so uh for
people just listening that there is
whatever the mixture this is all this is
ultra laminar reversible flow so this
probably has to do something to do with
the material
we're used to mixing not being a
reversible process exactly that's what
that shows and then he he then reverses
the mixing it's able to do it perfectly
that's right so that's like the Futures
are past these it shows that Free Will
is an illusion just kidding okay well
basically there's there's you know some
environments where you know the
equations are like time symmetrical so
you can right
um and this is one model sort of it's an
interesting visual model for what's
happening in the world as we
redecentralize after the centralized
entry right so
um basically you know I mentioned the
internet Frontier over opens back in the
Western frontier closed today we
experienced covid-19 back then we
experienced a Spanish Flu Tech
billionaires and the other Captain
street right today Founders like Elon
and Dorsey
are starting to win against
establishment journalists back then Ida
Tarbell demagogued and defeated
Rockefeller I think net net Founders win
this time versus the journals back then
the journalist won over the founders
okay
um today we have cryptocurrencies back
then we had private banking today this
is an amazing one we have a populist
movement movement of digital gold
advocates
back then because Bitcoin maximalists
and so on where gold has become populist
because it's against the printing money
and so and so forth back then we had a
populist movement against gold in the
form of William Jennings Bryan in the
cross of gold speech gold was considered
a tool of big business now gold is the
tool against big business and big
government right
uh digital gold yeah digital gold right
say we have the inflation and cultural
conflict of Weimar like America back
then we had the inflation and cultural
conflict of Weimar Germany today we
environment America we have Ryan left
fighting in the streets same
unfortunately in Weimar Germany Peter
church has written about you know today
we have what turchan considers
Antebellum like polarization like
preborn polarization back then you know
if you go further back in time we had
what we now know to be Antebellum
pearlization right okay we have Airbnb
back then we had flop houses today we
have Uber back then we had Gypsy cabs
um you know so today we see the
transition from neutral to yellow
journalism back then we saw the
transition from yellow to neutral
journalism right
um and you know today figures like Mike
Moritz who you know wrote about China's
energetic and America's laconic but back
then Bertrand Russell actually wrote
this whole long book actually you know
the mathematician return Russell right
wrote this whole long book which I
didn't even realize he wrote about these
kind of topics
um about uh the problem of China and one
of his observations was uh you know
again this I'm not saying this is I'm
just saying he made this observation he
was saying that America was energetic
and China laconic at the time because
everybody was in opium dens and so on
and so forth okay more examples the one
I just mentioned where the Chinese and
Russians are again lining up against the
West except this time the Chinese are
the senior partner in the very
relationship rather than Junior partner
today I think in the second Cold War
there will also be a third world but
this time I think that third world might
come in first because it's not the
non-aligned movement it's the Align
movement around web 3 protocols
that's fascinating yeah that's where
India comes in by the way something we
haven't mentioned Africa that there
could be very interesting things in
Africa as well Nigeria is actually
Nigeria says First Tech unicorn
um and I'm investing there I've uh and I
think you know it's one of these things
where China's risen India is like about
10 years behind uh you know China but I
think this is uh the Indian decade in
many ways we can come back to that point
um but there's absolutely you know
Sparks of light in Africa I mean it's a
huge continent you know I was like the
more behind side to interrupt the more
behind you are
the more opportunity you have to leap
for all sometimes that's right and pays
a is a classic example where they did
this in in East Africa but uh but I
think there's more possibility there
um so what is uh the fact that this uh
there's a kind of symmetry there's a
history right what is that um how do how
did that take us from uh um
Trump the the different perspective you
took the libertarian perspective of uh
it doesn't really matter yeah because
the libertarian perspective or the left
left libertarian perspective would say
is it really a good idea to have
total corporate power against the quote
elected government even if you know you
may disagree do you want to open the
door to Total you know corporate
oligarchy and it's like the opposite
that's why I mentioned it's like the
opposite of business plots and they
pulled on that thread Okay so
um the the macro explanation that I have
for this future is our past thesis and
there's more it also gives some
predictions right if you go backwards in
time the U.S federalizes into many
individual states like before the Civil
War people said the United States are
and after they said the United States is
before FDR the 10th Amendment reserved
rights to the states afterwards it was
just Federal Regulation of everything
as we go forwards in time you're seeing
States break away from the feds on gun
laws drug laws right Sanctuary cities
okay
um many other kinds of things you know
and now Florida for example has its own
guard that's like not uh a National
Guard but like a state guard other other
cities uh other states are doing this
and that's the force of decentralization
is saying that parallels yes in Reverse
in Reverse right so you're having before
make America States again
nice okay that's what's I think
happening right but I'm not saying I
well I think there's aspects of that
that are good there's aspects that are
bad but
um just like that's kind of the the
angle right
but then that's I mean from your
perspective that's probably not enough
right that's that's not um it's part of
the Future Let's just say whether I
think use in such inter trouble you
suggested all kinds of ways to build
different countries I think that's
probably one of them you said like start
micro micro countries or something like
this I forgot the terminology yeah
micronations yeah I actually think of
them as is better term as microstates
because they're actually not Nations
that's why they don't work but
microstates are better right uh coming
back to the difference between the
nation the state the nation is like
the nation-state is a term that people
use without expanding it but Nation
comes from the same root word as like
natality so it's like common descent
common birth right common origin like
the Japanese Nation that's a group of
people that have you know come down from
history right against nationalism yeah
whereas the state is like the
administrative layer above them it's
like labor and capital like or labor and
management okay the American state stood
over the Japanese nation in 1946 after
the war right oh so you weren't talking
about traditionally you know that that
doesn't matter
like I thought you meant nation is a
thing that carries across the
generations that there's a tradition
there's a culture and so on and state is
just the management the uh the layer I
mean that's also that's also another way
of thinking about it right there's a
reversals there as well okay yeah so so
I mean one way of thinking about it is
um you know one nation under God
indivisible is no longer true it is
America is at least two Nations the
Democrat and Republican in the sense of
their own cultures where I can show you
graph after graph you've seen the
polarization graphs I can show you
Network diagrams where you know like
there's this graph of polarization in
Congress where there's red and blue
they're separate things there's this
article from 2017 showing
um how uh you know shares on Facebook
and Twitter are just separate sub graphs
they're just separate graphs in The
Social Network and they're pulling apart
those are two Nations uh they're not
under God because people in the US no
longer believe in God and they're very
much divisible because
uh 96 of Democrats won't marry
Republicans in a high percentage other
way and in one gen what that means is in
one generation ideology becomes biology
these become ethnic groups it takes on
the character of hudu and Tootsie or
Protestant and Catholic Sunni and Shiite
it's not about ideology if you think
about old flips during covid right where
people were on one side where cellular
side it's Tribal it's just tribe on
tribe and so it's not Universalist that
identity of American makes less sense
than the identity of Democrat and
Republican right now or perhaps they
don't do evangelial states where I think
that's a good or bad thing I think
that's unfortunately you know whatever
it is hour of History right on the
opposite side of things India is
actually was 562 princely States at the
time of Indian unification
um in 19 from 1947 to 19 1947 when they
got independence from the British it was
562 princely States most people don't
know their part and got your outside and
you don't know the part it got unified
into a republic only by like 1950. and
India is like actually a modern Crea
India is like Europe it's kind of like
the European Union in the sense that we
didn't have a unified India in the past
it was something a lot of different
countries like
Northern South India or like Gujarat and
Tamil Nadu are as different as
Finland and Spain okay but India has
moved in the direction of much more
unification like much more you know
um centralization or what have you
whereas the US is decentralizing you go
okay
a few more things there are Flips and
I'll finish this off today we're seeing
the rise of the pseudonymous founder and
startup societies back all the way back
in the 1770s we saw pseudonymous
founders of Starbuck countries namely
the US right Federalist Papers
um today we're seeing so far
unsuccessful calls for wealth seizures
in the U.S back then we saw FDR's
executive verse 6102 which was a
successful seizure of gold I expect we
may see something like that an attempted
seizure of digital gold and I think
that'll be one of the things that
individual states like Florida or Texas
may not enforce that and I think that's
actually the kind of thing where you
could see you know like a breakup
potential in the future right one other
thing that kind of Rhymes is in many
ways like the modern U.S establishment
the story that you hear is the victories
in 1945 and 1865 legitimate the current
establishment that is being the Nazis
being the Confederates right so you beat
the ethnic nationalists abroad and they
beat the quote secessionist at home
right and uh the ethnic nationalists
were you know Aryan Nazis and the
secessionists were you know slave slave
owners and against freedom and so on and
so forth okay I'm not disputing that I'm
just saying that that's just like
they're the way people think about it
there's a possibility and I'm not saying
it's 100 at all okay but if you're a
Sci-Fi writer
there's a possibility that the U.S loses
to the ethnic nationalists abroad except
this time they're Chinese Communists
non-white Communists as opposed to Aryan
Nazis which seemed like the total
opposite okay
and uh there's a possibility that there
is a
um Financial secession at home where
it's you know Bitcoin maximalist states
that are advocating for Freedom the
opposite of slavery
see what I'm saying
oh boy that's dark you're uh you're
looking for major things in history that
don't yet have a cognate going forward
right and that's a nice way to think
about
the future it is only one model and you
know any mental model or something like
that that's why I say as a Sci-Fi
scenario it's like a scenario one could
contemplate right where the new version
has I mean the Chinese Communists do not
think of themselves as Aryans right
um but they are alternationalist and you
know the Hitler comparisons people talk
about Hitler endlessly you know like
Saddam is a new Hitler everybody's a new
Hitler et cetera
if there is a comparison to quote Nazi
Germany it is
you know CCP China in a sense why they
are non-english speaking manufacturing
Powerhouse with a massive military build
out under one leader that is a genuine
peer competitor to the US on many
dimensions and in fact you know
exceeding on some dimensions of
technology and science right that is
like the problem is it's a boy who cried
wolf people say this a zillion times
right
um and you know that is like uh you know
I'm not saying this by the way crucially
I am there's like I think China is
uh very complicated and there's hundreds
of millions of people probably half in
China that disagrees with the current
alternationalist kind of thing right and
so I kind of hate it when
innocent Chinese people abroad or
whatever are just like attacked on this
basis or what have you plus the other
thing is that many times people say well
look relative to you know where we were
when uh Deng took over in 1978 we built
up the entire country we're not starving
to death anymore and the West wants to
recolonize us and so understand where
that's coming from this way you want to
be able to argue different points of
view with that said
there's one huge difference right which
is Nazi Germany was like 70 million
people
and the US was 150 million and the
Soviet Union was 150 million and the UK
was like 50 million so they were
outnumbered like five to one
[Music]
China outnumbers the U.S
four to one
this is going to be a fun Century things
are going to be under this model under
this model things are going to be
potentially crazy plus you know people
are like oh I think this is uh you know
again I have nothing personal you know
there's a guy Peter Zion he writes these
books right
I probably agree about 20 or 30 but I
disagree with a lot of the rest and a
bunch of it is basically about
how China is really weak and America is
really strong and the rest of the world
is screwed and
um you know I think there's absolutely
problems in China and uh you know like
the current management is actually
messing a lot of things up we could talk
about that
but I do think that
you know the US is like fighting its
Factory
so one thing you know Zion will talk
about is how oh America has this Blue
Water Navy all the aircraft carriers and
China has nothing it's got books et
cetera well China ships things all
around the world
right it probably has you know one of
the most active fleets out there in
terms of you know it's commercial
shipping
um and uh in terms of building ships
here's a quote China's Merchant shipping
industry is the world's largest building
more than 23 million gross tons of
shipping in 2020. US yards built a mere
70 000 tons the same year though they
typically average somewhere in the 200
thousands that is a 100 to 300X ratio
just in shipbuilding pretty much
everything else you can find in the
physical world is like that okay we're
not talking like 2x we're talking they
can put together a subway station in
nine hours with with prefab and the US
takes three years okay
when you have a thousand X difference in
the physical world
the reason the US was won against you
know Nazi Germany in a serious fight is
they have this giant manufacturing plant
that was overseas and they just out
produced right and they supplied the
Soviets also with lendlies and the
Soviets talked about how they would not
have won the war without the Americans
people are like oh the Russians you know
fought the Germans the Russians armed by
Americans fought the Germans like it's a
Soviet Union they're not actually able
to make high quality stuff there
obviously are individual people in
Soviet Russia who were Innovative right
I'm not taking that away there's a
there's a tradition of amazing I just
want to be like
um there's individual Russians who
obviously I admire Mendeleev and uh you
know clamor Grove and and so on there's
amazing Russian scientists engineers so
I'm not saying that I mean in general
from from uh yourself that criticized
communism is too easy to say
nothing communism produces is good uh
which of course is not true yes a lot of
people in and and a lot of even you know
there's a lot of amazing things have
been created yeah so they had some
amazing mathematicians amazing
scientists and so on right however great
branding on the you know red and the
yellows yeah yes The Branding is Stellar
so Nazi Germany to excellent branding
well the flag and so on you know so so
the lungs and ends there in terms of
compliments yeah well actually they
copied a lot of stuff from each other
you know like there's this movie called
the Soviet story it basically shows a
lot of Nazi and Soviet propaganda things
next to each other and you can see guys
almost in like the same pose it's almost
like uh you know how AI will do like
style transfer you can almost see
because the Socialist realism style of
like the muscular brawny worker very
similar to like the style of the Aryan
Superman you know like pointing at the
Vermin or whatever and then there's the
crappy open source version that tries to
copy which is Mussolini yeah that's just
like that does the same exact thing but
does it kind of shittier so right anyway
so my main thing about this is basically
like trying to fight your factory in the
physical world is probably not going to
work people are I think overconfident on
this stuff right with that said I think
we want to at all you know the future is
not yet determined right at All Odds you
know we want to avoid a hot war between
like I mean a hop war between the US and
China would be
do you think it's possible that we get a
war we're doing these things like Pelosi
going to Taiwan and trying to trying to
cause something like look again this is
one of these things which is complicated
because obviously if you're there's more
than one perspective on this right again
you've got the U.S establishment the U.S
conservative the Taiwanese perspective
the Chinese perspective all the
bystanders over there there's more than
one perspective on this okay if you're
you know China's one of China's many
neighbors
you look at China with apprehension like
Vietnam for example has sort of fallen
into uh or not falling into is
partnering with India because they're
mutually apprehensive China China is not
making like great friends with its
neighbors it's kind of you know it's
demonizing Japan it's it's so
ultra-nationalist nowadays
um and so if you're Taiwanese you're
like uh yeah I do not want to be under
the Chinese surveillance State I
completely understand that some people
are pro-reunification others aren't but
there's more you know Trend you know um
in some ways for for Independence okay
fine
but there's also an increasing
temperature across the entire world as
we sit here today there's speeches by
Vladimir Putin about the serious
possibility of a nuclear war
and that escalates kind of
the heat in the room of geopolitics it
escalates the human room of course right
and the thing is people have this belief
that because something hasn't happened
it won't happen or it can't happen but
like there were a lot of measures people
took during the Cold War
to
make sure a nuclear exchange didn't
happen the whole mutually sure
destruction thing and communicating that
out and like the balance of Terror there
were smart guys on both sides who
thought through this and there were near
misses right there you know like there's
that story about like the Soviet Colonel
who didn't order a nuclear strike
because he thought it was just like an
error in the instruments right okay
what's the point point is
you know for example Pelosi going to
Taiwan that didn't strengthen Taiwan
they didn't like that if if you're going
to go and provoke China I thought
scholar stages his Twitter account had a
good point which is you should if you're
actually gonna do it then you strengthen
Taiwan with like huge battalions of like
arms material and you make them a
porcupine and so on and so forth instead
her kind of going and Landing there and
mooning China and then flying back in
the middle of a hot war with Russia
that's absolutely you know in the middle
of an economic crisis or it just it just
okay you know can you can pick battles
or whatever right it's like you don't
have to fight Russia and China at the
same time
it's like kind of insane to do that okay
plus even with Ukraine
um some people are like oh this was like
a a victory for the U.S military policy
or something there's a guy who I'm not
trying to beat him up or anything he's
like this is in March threat on U.S
security assistance to Ukraine it's
working Ukraine might be one of the
biggest successes of U.S security
assistance and the reason is you know
U.S didn't focus on some high-end shiny
objects but on core military tasks that
focus should remain and it's like
how is this a success the West gave
massive arms to Ukraine only after the
invasion but not enough before to deter
and now Ukraine is like this syria-like
Battleground with you know a million
refugees or whatever the number is Right
their country is blown to Smithereens
thousands of people dead whatever
thousand dollar gas in in Europe with
like 10x energy radicalized Russians the
threat of World War III or even nuclear
war you know shooting somebody
isn't that's not like the point of a
military the point is you know there's a
million ways to smash Humpty Dumpty into
pieces and you know unleash the blood
drench Tides right and have people all
shooting each other and killing each
other it's really hard to maintain
stability that's what competence is
deterrence and stability right there's
not like a success in any way
um this is like an absolute tragedy for
everybody involved right yeah I mean
deterrence of course is the the number
one thing but there you know there's a
lot to be said there
um but I'm a huge not fan of declaring
Victory as we've done many times when
it's the wrong yeah I mean look I mean
the other thing about this is the whole
mission accomplished thing during it
accomplishes what I meant yeah exactly
mission accomplished was obviously you
know the thing is
Russia lives next door to Ukraine and so
I mean just like Iraq lives next door to
Iran and Afghanistan is next to Pakistan
and China and so if the U.S eventually
gets tired of it and leaves those guys
are next door right and so you know who
knows what's going to happen here okay
um but one of the problems is like you
know the whole Afghanistan thing or the
Iraq thing is the lesson for people was
the uncertainty they're like is the US
going to fight don't know is will the US
win if it fights don't know therefore
roll the dice that uncertainty is itself
like tempting to folks you know like
like pewter right so point is coming all
the way back up we were talking about
how history Futures are passed and FDR
like the business plot the FDR failed
but like the tech companies were able to
de-platform Trump right and the left
libertarian would say do we want that
much corporate power okay and so that's
so we gave the forecast for Trump to
platforming protecting democracy the
Trump supporter case against which is on
the secret history of the Shadow
campaign the state of the 2020 election
that article the left libertarian or
libertarian case against and then to me
what is uh you know like I am more
sympathetic to
the libertarian slash left libertarian
against and then also maybe the fourth
group which is the non-american case
right which is to say
every you know you know you know amlo
he's the uh he was a you know head of
state of Mexico I think at that time
okay
um amlo macron you know other folks
everybody who's watching this around the
world
basically saw
let's say U.S establishment or democrat
aligned folks just decapitate you know
the head of state from digitally right
like just boom gone okay and they're
like well if they can do that in public
to the US president who's ostensibly the
most powerful man in the world
what is the Mexican president stand
against that
nothing right like these U.S media
corporations use tech companies are so
insanely powerful everybody's on Twitter
or what have you other than China
leaving them aside they've got their own
root system if somebody tried to
de-platform decision paying off of Sino
weibo they're probably just fall through
a trap tour you know their whole family
right but for the rest of the world it's
on the that that is hosting their
business their Politics on these US tech
companies they're like regardless of
whether it was Justified on this guy
that means they will do it to anybody
now the seal is broken just like the
bailouts as exceptional as they were in
the first everybody was shocked about
them then they became a policy
instrument and now there's bailouts
happening every single bill is printing
another whatever billion dollars or
something like that